die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis
guten abend und herzlich willkommen der
sport heute für sie von norbert leben
und das sind die wichtigsten themen
heute
flammeninferno am mittelmeer tausende
menschen fliehen vor den bränden in
griechenland ein ende der feier ist
nicht in sicht
hoteliers in not nach der flutwelle im
urteil liegt auch der tourismus am boden
und endspurt in tokio der kajak-vierer
der männer holte das lang ersehnte gold
der deutschen rennsport kanuten
für die menschen in griechenland und der
türkei ist es ein albtraum seit mehr als
einer woche schafft man es nicht die
verheerenden waldbrände ganz zu löschen
an vielen orten lodert es weiter wir
schauen jetzt ausführlich dorthin und
beginnen mit griechenland eine so
gefährliche lage habe es noch nie
gegeben heißt es vom griechischen
katastrophenschutz mehr als 150 brände
seien in dieser woche ausgebrochen 64
loderten noch immer thomas concia war
die dramatische situation nördlich von
athen und auf der insel euböa
schnell zum strand mit dem nötigsten und
liebsten letzte rettung weg übers meer
bis ans wasser haben sich die flammen
herangefressen inferno im mittelmeer
paradies oliver die flucht gelingt per
fähre tausende kommen vergangenen nacht
an bord egal wie
touristen vor allem einwohner die
meisten lassen alles zurück was sie
haben
auch nach athen fliegen mensch und tier
ford von der flammenwand einige bleiben
trotz der gefahr irgendwo im raum
hilfeschreie schnell holt wasser
das kommt endlich per lkw die anwohner
löschen selbst so gut oder schlecht es
eben geht mit eimern und mülltonnen
feuerwehrleute sind vor ort aber nur
wenige sie vors arbeit einsam und
vergeblich
heute morgen waren die feier auf dem
berg aber da war kein löschtrupp dann
sind die flammen zu uns hier
untergekommen
auch der gouverneur der region fordert
mehr feuerwehrleute mehr löschflugzeuge
der regierungschef spricht von
lebensnotwendigen
prioritäten
seit tagen ist erstmal das
allerwichtigste menschen zu schützen und
zu verhindern dass das feuer in die
siedlungen vordringt
immerhin viele brände sind jetzt
gelöscht in den vororten von athen es
bleiben verwüstung und vernichteten
existenzen und
für uns in athen ist thomas meister
dominik sieht apokalyptisch aus wenn man
die bilder sieht wie kommen die
löscharbeiten voran
das ist unterschiedlich also wir haben
im norden von athen die situation dass
die feuerwehr heute im laufe des tages
erfolge vermelden konnte einige brände
konnte man dort löschen und man hofft
jetzt bis in den abend und die nacht
auch dieses gebiet unter kontrolle zu
bringen man hat heute auch den ganzen
tag kräfte dort konzentriert
hubschrauber dort konzentriert
löschflugzeuge an anderen stellen in
griechenland sieht das ganz anders
ausschauen wie zum beispiel auf den
peloponnes oder die zweitgrößte insel
da bieten diese brände weiter und
menschen hat man auch im beitrag gesehen
mussten zum teil die insel verlassen und
die situation ist aktuell dort auch noch
dramatisch und man merkt dass die
griechische feuerwehr hier jetzt einfach
überlastet ist es fehlt an
löschflugzeugen es fehlt einfach an
personal an
feuerwehrleuten und deswegen auch der
hilferuf nach europa viele länder in
europa unterstützen ja schon auch
deutschland wird jetzt auch
feuerwehrleute nach griechenland
schicken um diese doch sehr heftigen und
extrem waldbrände irgendwie in den griff
zu bekommen vielen dank dominik
löschmeister
auch in der türkei halten die waldbrände
die menschen weiter in atem
mehr als 5000 helfer sind im einsatz
neben den einsatzkräften kämpfen auch
etliche freiwillige gegen die flammen
betroffen sind vor allem urlaubsgebiete
im süden und westen des landes es sind
die schwersten waldbrände der türkei
seit mehr als 13 jahren und
liegt weit ist für uns der nähe von
marmaris lück es gibt viel kritik an der
türkischen regierung warum
weil ganz offensichtlich eine mehrheit
der menschen und insbesondere betroffene
wie auch die helfer die wir hinter uns
sehen im ort
das ist etwa 50 kilometer nordöstlich
von marmaris die finden sich schlichtweg
im stich gelassen offensichtlich ist der
katastrophenschutz in besser
insbesondere der brandschutz hier nicht
so auf eine solche katastrophe
vorbereitet gewesen im fokus stehen da
die löschflugzeuge die türkei besitzt
eine flotte von 20 sehr veralteten und
offensichtlich gar nicht gewarteten
flugzeugen die waren nicht einsatzfähig
so dass also schon seit einer woche hier
russische spanische ukrainische
flugzeuge aus allen herren länder
unterwegs sind aber eben keine
türkischen die opposition hat das
natürlich aufgespießt und hat gesagt ein
präsident der für vieles geld und zeit
hat um einen kanal zu bauen am bosporus
um sich selbst eine große flotte von
flugzeugen zu leisten aber keine
löschflugzeuge und im netz gab es einen
dringenden hilfsappell an das ausland
bitte helft der türkei und die menschen
die sich jetzt dort geäußert haben im
netz gegen die ermittelt jetzt der
staatsanwalt schon 66
ermittlungsverfahren wurden eingeleitet
gegen leute die sich dort also gegen den
unzureichenden brandschutz hier im land
gewendet haben und öffentlich geäußert
haben also der präsident versucht es mit
repression er sieht selbst nicht gut aus
er war vor einer woche hier im
katastrophengebiet und hat te an die
menschen verteilt das hat den unguten
nur noch weiter angefacht und man
versucht jetzt in gewisser weise die
presse außen vor zu halten also schlicht
wäre schlichtweg die berichterstattung
etwas zu unterbinden die rundfunk
aufsichtsbehörde droht allen die
zunahmen das vorangehen und zu einseitig
über feuer berichten mit strafen das
gilt natürlich für türkische kollegen
aber auch wir merken wir kommen nicht
mehr ganz nah an die brandherde ran wir
sind auch vor einigen stunden von der
polizei von diesem brand hier in der
nähe entfernt worden vielen dank glück
wolpert aus der türkei
blicken wir auf die pandemie kurzform
bund-länder-treffen am dienstag gibt es
weiter diskussionen über mögliche
nachteile für ungeimpfte die politik
müsse alles unternehmen um ungeimpfte
zur impfung zu bewegen so der
vorsitzende des welt ärzte bundes
montgomery da nützten aber keine prämien
sondern nur rechte für geimpfte der
spd-politiker karl lauterbach fordert
dass ungeimpfte bei hohen instanzen
einen pcr-test vorlegen müssen etwa für
restaurantbesuche die korona zahlen in
deutschland steigen unterdessen weiter
leicht an das robert koch institut
meldete
3206 neuinfektionen bin 24 stunden 806
mehr als vor einer woche
24 menschen starben innerhalb eines
tages im zusammenhang mit 19 die sieben
tage incidents liegt bei
21,2
in einigen bundesländern sind die
sommerferien bereits zu ende in anderen
laufen sie noch aber auch dort haben
zahlreiche kinder nicht frei weil sie
büffeln all das aufholen was wegen der
geschlossenen schulen im lockdown nicht
unterrichtet wurde in thüringen zb gibt
es dafür extra ferienkurse florian kojak
hat sich ein angeschaut
englisch üben in der grundschule an der
wachsenburg mitten in den ferien
die kinder sind freiwillig hier mehr
oder weniger
nicht ganz so viele engel stimme ich
denke auch dass in dem homescreen ganz
besonders die sprachen einfach zu kurz
gekommen sind sprache lebt davon dass
man sie spricht hunderte solcher
kostenloser kurse finden gerade in
thüringen statt geleitet vom studenten
bis zum rentner finanziert aus dem
schulbudget das zuletzt nicht
ausgeschöpft wurde die vielen kunden
sind kein klassischer unterricht aber
wenn natürlich jetzt ein englischkurs
gemacht da gibt es natürlich und
unterricht unterstützende maßnahmen im
sinne tragen sie dazu bei auch
versäumten stoff nachzuholen geplant ist
die kurse nach den sommerferien weiter
anzubieten experten wie der unterrichts
forscher alexander kirchner begrüßen die
maßnahmen aber unsere sorge ist es ist
diejenigen erreicht wurden die wir sonst
auch erreichen nämlich die kinder aus
bildungsnahen elternhäusern und die
sorge ist dass die kinder nicht erreicht
werden dies eigentlich brauchen nur
damit die soziale schere weiter aufgeht
auch sportkurse wie etwa schwimmen
fanden monatelang kaum statt aktuell
sind bundesweit hunderte ehrenamtliche
im einsatz damit aus einer generation
corona nicht auch noch eine generation
nicht schwimmer wird
in frankreich sind heute erneut mehr als
100.000 menschen auf die straße gegangen
weil sie nichts von den verschärften
coroner regeln der regierung halten die
nächste woche in kraft treten sollen am
donnerstag hatte der französische
verfassungsrat grünes licht gegeben für
eine impfpflicht für das
gesundheitspersonal und für einen
gesundheitspass derzeit ob jemand
geimpft oder negativ getestet wurde
hannah arendt über die proteste
der widerstand wächst nachdem
frankreichs pandemie politik lange kaum
massenproteste ausgelöst hat treiben nun
gesundheitspass und impfpflicht etwa für
krankenhauspersonal viele franzosen auf
die straße wir sind nicht gegen die
impfung aber gegen den pass und die
damit verbundenen einschränkungen des
opfers wo der gesundheitspass ist nur
dafür da um uns zugänge uns
vorzuschreiben was wir dürfen und was
nicht
rechtsextreme versuchen diesen unmut
politisch auszunutzen
gast nun antritt unsere freiheit mit
füßen und die gleichheit vor dem gesetz
das wollen wir nicht akzeptieren
gemeint ist eine deutliche verschärfung
der maßnahmen ab montag nur wer geimpft
gewesen oder negativ getestet ist erhält
zutritt zu den meisten öffentlichen
einrichtungen die regierung will so den
impf druck erhöhen videos aus dem
sommerurlaub
lassen sie sich impfen das ist eine
bürgerpflicht freiheit ist nur etwas
wert wenn man die freiheit des anderen
schützt
antwort auf all jene die heute wieder
die freiheits parole vor sich her tragen
dabei offenbart der protest auch risse
die durch frankreichs gesellschaft gehen
die summe kann der präsident spaltet das
land und provoziert anfeindungen wir
beobachten dass er mit vertrauensverlust
zu kämpfen hat
und so könnte dieser protest sommer zur
vorrunde für die präsidentschaftswahl in
neun monaten werden
in mehreren deutschen städten haben
heute hilfs organisationen wie amnesty
international und ärzte ohne grenzen für
eine unterstützung der zivilen
seenotrettung im mittelmeer demonstriert
die schiffe sie bot 3 und ocean viking
bekamen heute die erlaubnis wenn mehr
als 800 geflüchteten in sizilien
anzulegen nach angaben der vereinten
nationen ertranken dieses jahr bei der
flucht über das mittelmeer schon mehr
als 1000 menschen
polen geht auf die eu zu zumindest in
einem wichtigen punkt der unabhängigkeit
von richterinnen und richtern der chef
der regierungspartei peace kaczynski hat
die auflösung der umstrittenen
disziplinarkammer angekündigt nach
ansicht der eu kommission sollte diese
kammer vor allem die politische
kontrolle über die justiz sicherstellen
weil das gegen die europäischen verträge
verstößt hatte sie polen mit geldstrafen
gedroht
in nordrhein westfalen haben rund 2500
menschen für einen schnelleren
kohleausstieg demonstriert am tagebau
garzweiler bildeten sie eine vier
kilometer lange menschenkette zwischen
den dörfern vize rad und kein berg
lutzerath soll als erstes für den
kohleabbau verschwinden ob noch weitere
orte weichen müssen ist unklar die
demonstrierenden forderten den
kohleausstieg bis 2030 die
bundesregierung will ab 20 38 auf den
abbau von braunkohle verzichten
in den flutgebieten in
nordrhein-westfalen und rheinland-pfalz
stapelt sich immer noch das was von
häusern straßen und brücken übrig
geblieben ist allein der wiederaufbau
des anteils könnte eine zweistellige
milliardensumme kosten schätzt die
bürgermeisterin der verbandsgemeinde
altenahr weigand touristinnen kommen
zurzeit natürlich keine hotels und
gaststätten fürchten pleite zu gehen
susanne gelhard berichtet
in bad neuenahr wollte christian lindner
in seinem hotel aurora 111 jähriges
jubiläum feiern dann kam die flut gäste
und familie konnte er in letzter minute
retten sein hotel hat schwer gelitten so
wie alle im alltag
hier ist ein landstrich von 40
kilometern ungefähr einfach mal zu 80
prozent zerstört worden wir haben 62
brücken verloren alleine also alleine
diese infrastruktur aufzubauen drumherum
wird sehr sehr lange dauern eineinhalb
millionen übernachtungen im aartal das
war einmal ein wirtschaftlicher
totalschaden meint der branchenverband
und fordert schnelle finanzielle hilfe
es sind ja nur 40 prozent der betriebe
circa elementar versichert und alle
anderen haben alles verloren wir müssen
diesen leuten eine möglichkeit geben vor
weihnachten noch eine kleine art von
geschäft zu machen und den leuten auch
eine perspektive zu bieten mit wandern
und wein wird das ahrtal doch jetzt sind
hunderte kilometer straße weggerissen
die aartalbahn die die orte miteinander
verbindet samt bahnhöfen zerstört ohne
diese infrastruktur hat der tourismus
keine chance der wiederaufbau der hotels
allein reicht nicht die dorfgemeinschaft
hat funktioniert und
jeder hat jedem geholfen wir haben sehr
viel hilfe von außerhalb gekommen und
jetzt gerade rücken diese freiwilligen
helfer wieder nach zwei wochen ab und
wir haben jetzt angst dass wir in drei
wochen ganz alleine hier stehen
jetzt sind bund und land am zug damit es
wieder aufwärts geht
kommen wir zur norbert und zehnten
goldmedaille für das deutsche team bei
den olympischen spielen ja und jetzt
gleichzeitig die ersehnte erste
goldmedaille für die rennkanuten der
erfolgsverwöhnte kajak-vierer siegt nach
2016 in rio auch in tokio in der
königsklasse über 500 meter und das in
einem packenden finale
es ist ein kopf an kopf oder besser ein
punkt angucke rennen der deutsche
kajak-vierer seit vielen jahren
ungeschlagen absolute weltklasse und die
spanier die großen konkurrenten um die
ersehnte goldmedaille spannender
zweikampf
anfangs liegen die iberer foren erst in
den allerletzten sekunden schiebt sich
das deutsche paradeboot vorbei gewinnt
mit einem knappen meter vorsprung gold
es war nicht so einfach wie es
vielleicht aussah aber wahnsinnig geiles
geführt und für den 39-jährigen cannoli
ronald rauhe ist das olympia-gold in
seinem letzten rennen der absolute
höhepunkt seiner karriere
ich wusste vorher was was ihr auch
stiefel für mich ich wollte mich grüne
mit dem goldenen abschluss die jungs
haben wir es mir leicht gemacht wenig
später durfte sich ronald rauhe noch
über eine besondere ehre freuen bei der
schlussfeier am sonntag wird er die
deutsche fahne tragen
[Musik]
constanze klosterhalfen hat trotz einer
starken vorstellung nicht in den kampf
um eine medaille über 10.000 meter
eingreifen können die deutsche
rekordhalterin wurde achte ja und ganz
große enttäuschung beim speerwurf
top-favoriten johannes vetter der
weltjahresbeste haderte mit dem anlauf
und wurde mit schwachen 82 meter 52 nur
neunter der blick leer der favorit
fassungslos seit jahren dominiert
johannes vetter die konkurrenz doch
heute fliegt er vorzeitig raus erreicht
mit 82 metern 52 nicht einmal das finale
ist schade es echt bitter kotzt mich
auch tierisch an wie gesagt vor allem
für die leute die hier daheim da so sehr
die daumen gedrückt haben seine
dynamische anlauf technik und sein
kraftvoller stimme schritt passen nicht
zum für olympia neu entwickelten weichen
rutschigen belag und für die leute wie
mich jetzt ausgerechnet die heute ein
bisschen härter da hinstellen für die
ist der boden hat mitgemacht die
rutschte weg und die versuchs- und holz
von der leistung also ich habe alles
gegeben für den zweiten deutschen
starter julian weber lief es besser mit
85 m 30 verpasst der mainzer nur knapp
große wird vierter gold geht an den
inder schubra
der weltverband der modernen fünfkämpfer
hat die deutsche trainerin kim raisner
von den spielen in tokio ausgeschlossen
der grund die trainerin hatte das pferd
das der deutschen reiterin annika schleu
zugelost worden war und das im parcours
verweigerte mit der faust auf die flanke
geschlagen laut weltverband eine
verletzung des regierungs und
vorzeitiges ende der olympia premiere
des deutschen karate weltmeister
johannes horn während des zweiten
wettkampfes in der schwergewichtsklasse
verletzt er sich am ellenbogen schwer
noch vor ort wurde er erst nicht
notfalls olympiasieger wurde
vize-weltmeister sascha ott ganzer de
aus iran
und ausführlichen olympia sport wie
immer später bei uns im heute journal
blicken wir noch aufs wetter zurzeit
gelten unwetterwarnung für den süden
bayerns die gewitter serie setzt sich
morgen fort mehr dazu gleich beim wetter
von ist intelli das heute journal sehen
sie um 22 45 mit marietta slomka wir
sagen auf wiedersehen machen sie es gut
[Musik]
junge oder abend und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter heftige schauer und gewitter
in der ersten nachthälfte erwarten uns
noch dann verabschiedet sich dieses tief
die gewitter last nach es geht den
dauerregen über und später lässt das
dann auch im süden nach und so wird es
in der nacht aussehen erst einmal noch
heftige gewitter in den nächsten stunden
und in der ersten nachthälfte teils mit
starkregen in kurzer zeit große
regenmengen 40 örtlich sogar bis 60
liter gut möglich und auch größere alles
das ist noch möglich und dann
verschwindet das allmählich nach
nordosten ja und die temperaturen sinken
dabei auf 11 grad an den alpen und 17
grad im osten deutschlands und zum
morgen vormittag erst einmal überwiegend
trocken von westen her erste schauer zum
nachmittag dann vom main runter bis an
die alpen durchaus gewitter und auch im
norden gewitter im westen gibt es
schauer sonst nach osten hin trocken bei
höchsten temperaturen von 25 grad im
osten und 17 grad an den alpen die
kommenden tage am montag teils trockene
abschnitte im osten und im süden bis 25
grad oder ab dienstag weiterhin im süden
trocken im norden aber schauer und
wärmer ein schöner abend